[Applause]
people need to fear again they need to
dream again they need to live
again we can create a new world for
them this is a story about Christian
Dior creating the new look during World
War II he brought back fantasy and
elegance in a difficult time for Paris
the new look was the name of dior's icon
my first collection in
1947 it symbolized healing and brought a
nation back on its feet to understand
fashion today you've got to understand
the new
look it's a time of great
talent Chanel Bal
[Music]
Valen Dior was a young designer but Coco
Chanel was the Grand D of fashion and
was a worldwide celebrity I explore the
dark layers of her life humanity is
complex life is not all black or
white have you ever thought about what a
woman has to face to survive in this
world new man are new Wars new
rules these icons were forced to make
challenging decisions during World War
II Dior sister kathen is a resistance
fighter we feel we know so much about
these figures but the story really dared
to explore the sides that we've not
really considered
before this is a story of survival and
resilience fashion need a great
collection to Rise From the Ashes of The
Last 5 Years creation is our survival
our
Salvation we can interpret the pain in
the world through
creativity we have the capacity as human
beings to transform that spark is a
beautiful
spark it's time to show the world what
you've
[Music]
created